[موسيقى]
طيب بموضوع عرض المغادره الى احد البلدان
العربيه ايضا حتى اخر الايام ظلت هذه
العروض ساريه على الرئيس الاسبق وكان
يرفضها في احد الجلسات مع الرئيس صدام
حسين طبعا القائد المعتقل يتغير فاخر يعني
قائد المعتقل
امراه ضابطه امريكيه اسمها سات
فدخلت هاي القاعده الامريكيه ومعها
المترجمه
وطلبت من عندي ان لا اذهب بعد اللقاء مع
مدير مكتب الارتباط الامريكي مايكل ماكوي
وان اذهب معها
فالرئيس كان منتبه ورا ما طلعوا قلت لهم
ماشي يعني وافقت ما يفرق يعني
الضابط الاخر
بعد اللقاء
الرئيس اهتم بهالموضوع قال لي هذول عندهم
مبادره وعندها رساله تبلغك بها اريدك
تجيني ترجع لي باسرع وقت كان بذلك الوقت
اللقاء بالشهر مره واحده
فقال لي احتمال اذا هم يعني محتاجين هاي
المبادره توصلها لي راح ينطق يعني ينطوك
فرصه اخرى للمقابله خلال
[موسيقى]
لقيتها هي تقود المدرعه اللي انقل فيها
قلت لي
اني احمل مبادره ان تطلب يعني بحكم محبه
الرئيس الك واعتزازه فيك واهتمامك وثقتي
فيك احنا قواتنا في وضع حرج جدا بالفلوجه
تتقاتل يعني تنظيمات مسلحه وما لا يمكن ان
نسمح لامريكا ان تهان فاحنا اما ان نبيد
الفلوجه عن بكره ابيها بسلاح نوعي او
تهاني امريكا ولا يمكن ان تهاني ان نسمحين
العرض هو ان يخرج الرئيس يكتب لك رساله
للشعب
يكتب ما يشاء بها بس
لبه الرساله لب الرساله انه يكتب يطلب من
المسلحين وقف القتال وقف القتال والتفاوض
مع القوات الامريكيه مقابل هذا الى يعني
حددوا عده منها يطلق سراحهم ومنها يطلق
صراحه فورا خارج العراق خارج الى خارج
العراق
حددوا له ثلاث دول عربيه يختار اي دوله من
هاي الدول العربيه
واكدوا لي انه يعني جيبه متصل بالخزينه
العراقيه يعني ما يشيل هم الامور الماليه
او الامور المعيشيه ما يكتب مذكرات
يعتزل السياسه
ما يلتقي باحد يعني مجرد يعني حياه وحددوه
ثلاث عواصم عربيه حددوها
يعني ماذا قال لك عندما عرضت عليه ذلك
[موسيقى]